in campo io perché ero già paura che
questa vada vada ma adesso sono 16 km
meno male che c'è e io faccio le trovate
queste cose che non riguarda però andare
a 42 mi ha fatto fare
va bene basta iniziare vi prego grazie
ben attenti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video dove facciamo una mega ramp
ablin vada si chiama così gestito la
sala macchine blindate la marca che gli
da prevedere anche se cade a me
togliti aveva per la vedo abbastanza
semplice ecco che la state facendo raga
quantità metà ho perso il controllo ma
march conto se meno veloce ma oggi
machine fenomeno perché no è un fenomeno
più bravo a costruire ad alto non vi
vedo neanche per sbaglio io sto
scendendo
costruito della prossima rampa esatto ma
sai che volevo provarci una volta ma
rampa digitiamo per questo tempo non ce
lo abbiamo detto dalla rampa di margine
la rampa di marcia me li faccio fare un
click day thq amico sei le banche o no
ce l'ho fatta senza esplodere
incredibile mamma mia
bene possiamo facciamo veloce ragazzi
qua è stato solo bandirla no veramente
guidando stortissimo ragazzi cesto era
veramente odioso ecco lo guardi io ma e
mi servi sembra un attimino eccessivo
ragazzi chi è che sta lì nella rampa se
senti un rumore strano non ti
preoccupare chiunque 6 mar
sono vivo no vabbè incredibile sono
dietro marcino ma perché ma non non è
esploso ho volato per tipo otto
chilometri non è possibile che non sia
esploso ragazzi ci ho fatto un volo che
non esiste com'è possibile che non sia
esplosa la macchina esplodeva per un dio
io devo scappare più di due rampe vi di
fila rag
e io non ho fatte davvero a farsi tipo
36 pazzo quello è pazzo con le fa
rinchiudere noi ragazzi ragazzi o non
era in fretta ma in fretta una mazza
questo corpo dai a casa tua testa
meno male c'è un pezzo di ala che vola
siamo mai mancati farci mai perché aimar
5 st aereo di veder arci march arriva a
sinistra occhio così a roma che mamma
mia che ho fatto l'ho fatto
neanch'io siamo in due guardati indietro
po indietro dato che sia andata che
spunta come romana mamma mia che ansia
l'incredibile è veramente lenta ma noi
ci crediamo jolo
mamma mia va beh ma tu sei dieci
frontflip per forza e sono pure tenuta
lo odio la tenuta meglio di meno tenuta
troppo era già ove ne vado ciao ragazzi
stato bello però non sta andando
malissimo ss ecco visto ho detto
explorer non è male questa macchina non
esplode ma perché non lo sto prendendo
io non lo so chi sei pazzo dove sei ma
di fatto arrivare così mai fatto ad
arrivare a st melo si preve un po di
verde è meno visto tutto ok tutto ok
tutto bene quel che finisce bene cos'è
sta roba è un blindato è un blindato ma
allora obbligato ma che se cadi in piedi
non è su 99 l'ovvio però cerca di ieri
ciao amico mio
come hai fatto ad arrivare st velocità a
spiegare dove vai
è finita per me è ok ma mantengo me ne
vado dove stai andare come hai fatto
arrivare a st velocità spiega mi ha
neanche io che ti devo spiegare tutto a
caso ma che ne so tutta caròla velocità
ti permette di andare da una rampa
all'altra basta niente ritiro quello che
ho detto non è vero
e cazzo guarda forse mai inciso uguale
perché per per schivare tipo dovuto
buttarmi malissimo non lo so non me ne
vado avanti dai via avessi un cazzo
anormale forca vivere
mamma mia è ma è comunque letale che
schifo ce l'ha fatta tep campione
indiscusso di stampa gen
beh dal betis fi ma ti fai cavoli tuoi
ma te ne vuoi fare i cavolacci tuoi
progetti
no però però ho bisogno esserci stato un
jump square sta vivendo momenti di
panico non ci ho neanche pensato che
potesse mai via vai via
ciao ragazzi c'è veramente ci aiuta come
arrivarci sono sono così da the ok ti
prego aiutami risuonano sono mai da kara
crisi piano piano sono il tubo di lato a
sinistra dove hanno tiano vivi spingermi
ti prego eccoti è la somma che anche noi
ragazzi non ci credo è fatta davvero
benissimo mi sono pagato nello stesso
modo raga spingimi bravo poi come lo
faccio e arriva eccomi come faccio a
spingerti come faccio come faccio a
spostarti da lì come faccio
ma dov'è o dotate una botta di più è che
c'è il dosso ragazzi non mi butta vi si
buttano giù di sotto non usare non usano
stai privi di a spostarmi hai capito un
po come faccio non so se ti sei morto
insomma dall angolino in basso mi spiace
beta che si muove la macchina quindi la
mano o aspetta s'è mossa ma che deve
avere sempre della velocità massima si
muove ma guarda che per spostare march
colo se n'è andato non gli ha fregato
niente per fare strano devo fare è dare
una mano a noi che ci siamo incastrati
perdona ma la tesserino addio
già oggi non ci credo spetti come ce
l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta
non so come sempre ce l'ha fatta ci ha
sbloccato ha sbloccato a me e poi è
tornato giu lui perché mezzo è arrivato
da su 66 pure morto poi march non era
completata era andata giù a fallimenti
ha fatto un'altra auto cioè pensate che
aiuta abbiamo dato amarci ceci temi la
partita mi devi tipo qualche secondo in
più mi devi da casa su mike l'hai già
fatta aspetta che aspetta che non riesco
no vabbè muoio non so se stai vedendo
stesso mi dissocio perché voi verso
l'esterno perché vado io non sono caduto
quasi aiuto con che fisica non lo so so
cercare di tornare sul no e passo è
pazzo suo furgone teoricamente ci dovrei
essere io ormai ormai è fatto ma io vedo
un impegno per esplodere o greco bene ma
tenendosi turbo a cercando farci però
non l'ho trovato
a me non si pilota sta fare come diavolo
faccia uccidere
ma qualcuno vediamo allora più il
veicolo e vediamo come finisce
ah sì c'è un traguardo subito medi e ti
va bene anche te ne accorgi quindi
ragazzi questa era la big e rampe
blindata che non si è capito perché la
blindata ma l'abbiamo sbrindella
bravissimo step come sempre perché sulle
rampe maestro è march rotola ma certo
però che vi sia piaciuto cosa sia
piaciuto sottovento mi piace lo stato
anche dai cani march di stefan
descrizione e noi come sempre ci vediamo
alle pressioni e ragazzi
[Musica]